she was my best friend she was my soul  mate she was very supportive she was  loving she was in a wheelchair yeah she  never once mourned about her illness it  was barely a month ago that Teresa  Simpson died her husband says the time  it took for an ambulance to arrive when  she fell ill at home is to blame 16  hours and 45 minutes I wait I had to  wait and he only came the second time  because I rang him out of ring and bats  and my wife was lifeless 100 I believe  that if they got to my wife in six out  in within the six hours say from three  to nine o'clock my wife would still be  here now she would not be she wouldn't  I'm 100 that she would still be here  today because she would have got the  hell